die eigentums- und besitzrechte der
betreffenden völker an dem von ihnen von
alters her besiedeltem land sind
anzuerkennen
die rechte der betroffenen völker an den
natürlichen ressourcen ihres landes sind
besonders zu schätzen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
aufgepasst
gleichwertig zur tat sagen
[Musik]
da
um zu wachsen muss peru seine märkte
ausbauen
[Musik]
wir müssen mehr in öl und gas
investieren
[Musik]
ich bitte also um investitionen in peru
amerikanische unternehmer
wir sicherlich langfristige stabilität
zu
politische konflikte
als mitglied der amerikanischen
handelskammer würde ich in peru
investieren
natürlich
[Musik]
[Applaus]
alberto ist da
[Musik]
ich liebe den klub den amazonas ich
kenne nichts anders von hier komme ich
her
ich wuchs in einer gemeinschaft auf in
der wir die gaben der erde schützen
mein vater sagte immer wir würden uns
die erde nur leihen wir sollten nicht
einfach damit tun was wir wollen
wer sich etwas leid muss darauf
aufpassen mehr noch als der dem es
gehört
[Musik]
wir müssen sie den nächsten generation
in noch besserem zustand überlassen
seht ihr den teich
da gab es mal flussdelfine
früher habe ich mit ihnen gespielt
hallo herr lehrer
darf ich die kinder grüßen
mein sohn heißt übersetzt wasserfall und
du
die ureinwohner am amazonas folgen stets
dem prinzip naturschätze nicht
auszubeuten sondern sie zu respektieren
[Musik]
unser land ist uns heilig
unser land ist der samen unserer
existenz ohne das land wären wir
verloren
ich habe im wald ein wenig beute gemacht
wird etwas mehr zeit hätte ich noch mehr
jagen können
gut mein sohn anderswo gibt es mehr
teams hier
früher gab es hier viele tiere
sie liefen am fluss auf und ab
nichts ist mehr übrig
[Musik]
da ist die not peruanische ölpipeline
sie euch an versunken in wasser und
schlägt
und das sind die schäden die das öl in
der region hinterlässt
[Musik]
das rohöl ist bis hier oben gekommen
die hand wird schwarz davon auch hier
unten ist viel ruhe
im winter treibt das öl bis hier oben
und die fische ernähren sich dann von
den pflanzen
[Musik]
die meisten patienten leiden an
kopfschmerzen übelkeit und schwindel
das liegt daran dass auslaufendes öl das
wasser verschmutzt
unser wasser enthält viele giftige
metalle die unserer bevölkerung schaden
diejenigen gemeinden die durch den
kontakt blei und cadmium im blut haben
sind tod geweiht
[Musik]
die konzentrierte ansammlung von geld
und wohlstand
könnte diese entwicklung barbarisch
nennen
denn je ob man will oder nicht man tötet
den regenwald die kulturen ganze völker
[Musik]
präsident alan garcía reiste bis
peitsche sowie teil eines der grössten
ölvorkommen des landes fördern will
sehr aufregend
das sichert die zukunft unseres landes
und bietet neue chance
die regierung wird zu einem stahl gas öl
und mineralstoffe exporteur machen
präsident garcía wollte große
investitionen am amazonas fördern die
ureinwohner standen dem jedoch im weg
er ging soweit ihre territorien als
verschwendung zu bezeichnen immer besser
privat unternehmen verkaufen sollte
[Musik]
präsident alan garcía reiste voller
optimismus und mit hohen erwartungen in
die usa um das freihandelsabkommen zu
bewerben
ich bin sehr optimistisch
das abkommen wird ein großer schritt
nach vorn für unser land sein
präsident garcía verabschiedete gesetze
um ein freihandelsabkommen mit den usa
zu schließen
einige davon betrafen alle indigenen
bevölkerungen des amazonas regenwalds in
peru
er versuchte mit den gesetzen des
gemeinschafts land der indigenen
bevölkerung abzuschaffen oder zumindest
auszuhöhlen
einige gesetze zielten darauf ab
gemeinschaftseigentum abgeschafft
die gesetze gelten privaten unternehmen
das recht die rohstoffe des regenwaldes
auszubeuten auch ohne erlaubnis oder
absprache mit den eingeborenen vor und
die firmen bekamen einen blankoscheck
das freihandelsabkommen mit den usa ist
zustande gekommen
präsident garcía hat es am nachmittag
unterzeichnet
[Musik]
für uns ist das land fällig und
verkäuflich wir verhandeln nicht über
und salat
[Musik]
jäger sie us-regierung verstand das
nicht
[Musik]
wie gehts bruder
nicht denn hier jetzt ja schon
nicht zu sehen
sie sagen zu uns hier habt ihr etwas
geld damit wir gold und öl auf eurem
land abbauen können
das geld reicht zwei oder drei jahre
und dann
nichts
der fluss vergiftet das land verpestet
nichts bleibt
nur der tod wollt ihr das
[Musik]
warum verkauft alan garcía euer land
er sollte seines verkaufen dort öl
fördern
hat gold ab
warum will er uns in das ohr
wir können nicht weg
unsere ahnen lehrten uns unser land zu
verteidigen
unsere großeltern und eltern kämpften
für ihren anspruch auf das land
ohne das land sind wir nichts
gemäss konvention 169 haben wir ganz
klar das recht über das land unseres
volkes und unsere prioritäten zu
entscheiden
wir haben ein recht auf frieden
auf ein würdiges leben auf unserem land
die konvention 169 unterzeichnet diese
verpflichtet die regierung bei gesetzen
die die rechte von ureinwohnern
betreffen diese in die beratungen mit
einzubeziehen das ist nicht geschehen
außerdem sind die gesetze
verfassungswidrig
die verfassung garantiert den
ureinwohnern ihre rechte
präsidenten unserer landesorganisation
[Applaus]
ich bin anführerin einer gemeinde und
bin hier aufgewachsen
meine eltern nerven mich mit sauberem
wasser
mit der saubere luft und es frisches
essen
ich würde mein leben für den schutz
unseres landes unseres wassers und
unserer luft geben
unser anführer alberto ist hier also
sage ich und bringen sie unsere
botschaft zur peruanischen regierung
sagen sie ihnen dass wir existieren dass
auch wir peruaner sind wir sind
ureinwohner
aber wir sind auch peruaner
2009 beschlossen anführer der indigenen
völker stellvertretend für 1350
gemeinschaften gegen die gesetze der
regierung zu protestieren
[Musik]
was fordern die ureinwohner
gerechtigkeit die achtung unserer rechte
unseres landes und unserer tradition
hallo ich melde mich wegen der teilnahme
an den protesten
es vier boote voller menschen bringen
sogar 15
[Musik]
[Applaus]
dies ist ein friedlicher landesweiter
proteste in unseren angestammten
territorien
wir verlangen dass die regierung die
gesetze die gegen unsere grundlegenden
rechte verstoßen umgehend wieder ruft
[Applaus]
ethnische gruppen am amazonas streiken
sie wehren sich gegen gesetze durch die
seeland bedroht sehen in vier regionen
am amazonas öl protestiert sie warten
auf die antwort der regierung
in die kinos kam es zur größten
versammlung von ureinwohnern aller
zeiten
mehr als 500 ureinwohner versammelten
sich in traditionellem gewand um ihre
rechte einzufordern
wer für die proteste
es sind die ureinwohner gemeinden selbst
die die regierung ignoriert
wir haben hier zwei hochburgen mit etwa
3000 leuten aber jung und vampir
ureinwohner und leute die spanisch
sprechen
im kongress gibt es keine ureinwohner
die uns vertreten nur reiche leute die
die interessen der transnationalen
firmen schützen wollen
es folgt die mandat seines volkes
wir sind lediglich das sprachrohr der
entscheidungen unserer eingeborenen
brüder
die ureinwohner haben entschieden dass
die proteste andauern werden bis die
regierung auf unsere forderungen eingeht
wir bitten die regierung sich umgehend
mit uns zu treffen um bedauerliche
konsequenzen zu vermeiden
mit rohstoffen wie öl gas und holz sowie
dem enormen fischreichtum des amazonas
können wir vielen menschen arbeit geben
das gehört nicht nur dienen die durch
zufall dort geboren wurden
der amazonas gehört euch und euren
kindern er gehört der ganzen nation
der reichtum der ruß gehört ein peruaner
und sollte uns allen von nutzen sein
wir sprechen heute mit alberto pizango
präsident von einem cent
die protestierer und weil wir uns heute
hier erklären worum es geht
wir wehren uns nicht gegen den
fortschritt mann verteufelt uns gerne
sagt wir eingeborenen wäre nur
unruhestifter
ein haufen wilde die den fortschritt
nicht verstehen darum hält man uns für
fortschritte
das stimmt aber nicht
wir freuen uns über fortschritt für das
land sind aber nicht bereit dafür leben
zu gefährden
du kannst nicht durchgehen
lass dir nicht durch
die polizei
die gruppe steht hier und bewegt sich
nicht weg
[Musik]
aufgrund der straßensperren der
ureinwohner leiden tausende menschen in
san martin denn die grundversorgung mit
waren und dienstleistungen nicht
funktioniert
gruppe von eingeborenen blockieren die
straße die theorie
in einer machtdemonstration haben sie
auch die hauptstrasse von julia gaß
eingenommen
einige von ihnen campieren sogar auf der
straße
überall am amazonas standen lastwagen
staatliche regierungen forderten eine
lösung des problems da durch die
blockade die grundversorgung gefährdet
war
ich leitete eine kommission die sich mit
den ureinwohnern und ihrem
repräsentanten alberto pizango treffen
sollte
das treffen dauerte mehrere tage
der staat hat die ureinwohner am
amazonas jahrhunderte lang
vernachlässigt
die regierung unter präsident garcia
wird diesen missstand vom heutigen tage
an beenden
wir werden die gesetze überarbeiten und
die teile die unsere eingeborenen brüder
betreffende ändern
wir werden diese spezifischen teile
entfernen ohne dabei jedoch unserem land
zu schaden
wir sind zuversichtlich dass wir
aufgrund der heutigen fortschritte
dauerhafte lösungen finden werden
wir baten sie die spezifischen artikel
zu benennen mit denen sie problemlagen
wir fragten sie welche artikel streichen
sollten
sie sagte jedoch nur den abschaffen
abschaffen
alles oder nichts
da kommen sie
es war ein produktives treffen
jedoch wurde keine einigung erzielt
insgesamt war es eine positive
angelegenheit wir erhoffen uns von den
kommenden stunden konkrete ergebnisse
mehr kann ich aktuell nicht dazu sagen
wie können wir den änderungen zustimmen
wenn die gesetze hinter unserem rücken
gemacht werden ohne uns einzubeziehen
sie sind verfassungswidrig und gehören
abgeschafft
wir können keine sofortige lösung
erwarten wenn wir ehrlich mit der
bevölkerung perus sein wollen
wir brauchen eine langfristige lösung
zum wohle unseres landes
weiter protestieren mehr kann ich nicht
sagen morgen bekommen sie weitere
neuigkeit
[Musik]
die hunde dass die ureinwohner mit
speeren und gesichtsbemalung in
traditioneller bekleidung haben die
anlage nummer 6 von petrom peru in
loretto umzingelt
nach und nach kamen mehr und mehr
mitglieder der ureinwohner gemeinden den
schloss entlang mit booten aus
entlegenen regionen
sie wollten ein wichtiges ziel einnehmen
in die aufmerksamkeit der regierung zu
bekommen
in diesem fall war es die anlage nummer
wir sprachen mit dem leiter der anlage
von pedro peru darüber die ölpipeline zu
schließen
wir wollten die regierung unter druck
setzen
sie wussten dass wir das ganze land mit
öl versorgt
[Musik]
heute zu gast ist präsident von einer
sap alberto pizango guten abend
guten abend vielen dank für die
einladung und diese gelegenheit
sie haben eine pipeline von pedro peru
übernommen
sollte die gasversorgung zusammen
brechen gäbe es sind immer keinen strom
mehr und die stadt würde im chaos
versinken trotz alledem weigern sie sich
die proteste einzustellen
nichts davon wäre geschehen wäre die
regierung auf die forderungen der
ureinwohner eingegangen
wir hatten schon bedenken geäußert bevor
die gesetze in kraft traten ist ihnen
bewusst dass sie das ganze land
gefährden
und was ist mit den rechten der
eingeborenen
auch wir sind peruaner sie gehen mit
ihrer gemeinschaft ein gewaltiges risiko
ein senior pisa die auflösung der
proteste steht kurz bevor
das land kann nicht einfach ihretwegen
im stillstand verharren
[Musik]
das gesetz schützt die unternehmen und
ihre interessen
jedoch niemals die grundrechte und die
gebietsansprüche der ureinwohner
ich bin nicht bereit im dunkeln zu
sitzen nur weil sie nicht zu einem
dialog bereit sind niemand in der stadt
will das vielen dank ich hoffe sie
zeigen in zukunft mehr
dialogbereitschaft
wir sind dialogbereit
das wird leider nicht so vielen dank
sie protestieren seit mehr als einem und
und es ist keine lösung in sicht
wenn wir mit dem protest aufhören fragen
sie den präsidenten wenn er die gesetze
aufhebt dann gehen wir mit genug
politischen willen lassen sich alle
probleme lösen
wir bleiben hier und tragen die
konsequenzen
diese menschen sind keine könige sie
sind nicht bürger erster klasse
400.000 eingeborene können nicht 28
millionen peruaner vor schreiben sie
hätten kein recht hierher zu kommen das
geht nicht
es ist als sehnten sie für uns alle eine
primitive zeit herbei
die regierung war bisher sehr geduldig
aber das land kann nicht auf dauer mit
der pistole an der schläfe weitermachen
die regierung muss stärke zeigen und die
ordnung wieder herstellen das volk
erwartet ordnung vom staat wir müssen
ein ende erwirken
[Musik]
damit die regierung hat in vier regionen
am amazonas den notstand ausgerufen
die regierung war stets bemüht geduld
und toleranz walten zu lassen
diese aufhöre ist aber untragbar und
zielt darauf ab unsere regierung als
verwundbar und schwach darzustellen
das können wir nicht zulassen
wir werden unsere verfassungsgemäße
autorität in vollem maße zur geltung
bringen
ich möchte mit diesem einen herren
sprechen alle anderen bleiben bitte
zurück
kamen sie
bringen wir doch hier
ja bitte
ich führe die polizei spezialeinheit an
wir stimmen ihrem protest und ihren
forderungen zu
können sie aber nicht unterstützen
ich muss sie daher bitten die brücke
friedlich zu verlassen
ihr seid nicht unser feind
der kampf gilt der regierung
brüder soldaten
ihr seid nicht unser feind ist
ein verräter
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
ebenso wie der präsident den notstand
ausgerufen hat rufen auch wie
eingeborenen einen notstand in unseren
gebieten aus
das verwaltungs komitee unseres kampfes
hat entschieden unser volk zum aufstand
aufzurufen
daher werden wir nur noch unseren
traditionellen von unseren vorfahren
überlieferten gesetzen folgen
jedes eindringen von streitkräften in
unserer territorien werden wir als
aggression von außerhalb betrachten
warum stellen sie den dialog mit der
regierung
es ist ein elend die nächsten schritt zu
machen und die gesetze aufzuheben
unsere haltung ist seit langem klar
aufhebung der gesetze oder tod das ist
die entscheidung des volkes
dies erfordert ein blutvergiessen heraus
verschickt tausende eingeborene zum
scharfrichter
eingeborene die nur in frieden leben
wollen und angelogen werden
wir wollen keine gewalt wenn die
regierung geht auch dieser ansicht ist
sehen wir uns gezwungen den aufstand zu
beenden
[Musik]
wir werden unseren protest dennoch
fortführen denn das ist unsere gutes
recht
[Musik]
wir waren 38 polizisten inklusive
kommandant montenegro
wir sollten bei anlage nummer sechs ruhe
und ordnung waren
38 polizisten sind nicht genug wenn 1500
menschen vor den toren stehen
[Musik]
ihre anführer sagen uns dies ist ein
friedlicher protest
trotz des notstandes möchten wir ihnen
mit respekt begegnen
es soll nicht zu verletzten oder
schlimmeren kommen
wir sehen alle peruaner und lieben unser
land
wir unterzeichneten eine vereinbarung
mit der polizei einander nicht
anzugreifen
[Musik]
unsere gegner diesem kampf war nur die
regierung die judikative und die
legislative niemand sonst
die proteste halten nun seit 50 tagen an
doch das problem ist immer noch dasselbe
werden die gesetze nicht aufgehoben wird
weiter protestiert
[Musik]
da die exekutive keine schritte zur
lösung des problems unternahm wandten
wir uns an die parteien im kongress
wir wandten uns nach und nach an alle
politischen parteien
[Musik]
ich muss ihm zehn verzweifelt
organisiert eine vertretung
also
dieses dokument enthält unsere
forderungen
besonders umstritten war gesetzt 10 90
das forstgesetz
gemäß dem neuen fonds gesetz konnten
teile des regenwaldes die bisher als
gemeinschaftliche natürliche ressource
unter obhut des staates galten in
private hände verkauft werden
unsere eingeborenen brüder haben
entschieden bei aufhebung von gesetzen
90 die proteste zu beenden
[Musik]
bei den verhandlungen im kongress
setzte die regierung ihre eigene partei
unter druck
sie sagten dass schon durch die änderung
eines einzigen punktes oder commerce in
diesen gesetzen
das gesamte freihandelsabkommen in sich
zusammenfallen würde
das war eine lüge
das land der ureinwohner hatte nichts
mit dem freihandelsabkommen zu tun
überhaupt nichts das war der große
betrug von alan garcías regierung
[Musik]
kassier hatte die mehrheit im kongress
und seine partei stützte ihren
präsidenten wenn er die gesetze nicht
aufheben wollte würden sie nicht
aufgehoben werden
am 56 tag der proteste gelang es der
opposition im kongress eine debatte über
das forstgesetz 10 90 anzustoßen
ich denke der kongress unternimmt einen
sinnvollen schritt hin zur lösung dieses
problems
auch wenn es nur ein gesetz ist ja auch
bei nur einem
wir hoffen jedoch dass die anderen
fraglich in die sätze als
verfassungswidrig anerkannt werde
der streit um die aufhebung des
postgesetzes 10 90 wird weitergehen
wir stimmen nun über den antrag ab die
debatte über dieses gesetz auszusetzen
bis die exekutiv kommission ihre
empfehlungen zur aufhebung oder änderung
des gesetzes vorstellt
ich bitte um anwesenheits feststellung
für die abstimmung
die partei von präsident garcía stellt
unangekündigt einen antrag weitere
debatten über vorausgesetzt 10 90 zu
vertagen und stimmt noch bevor viele
mitglieder der opposition ein treffen
darüber ab
registrieren sie sich zur abstimmung
wir stimmen über den antrag ab
registrieren sie sich für die abstimmung
die abstimmung ist beendet
38 stimmen da
421 dagegen
neun enthaltungen der antrag wird
angenommen fahren wir fort
sehen wir dachten die interessen des
volkes
[Applaus]
ich bitte um ruhe
wir wollen eine debatte über ideen
[Applaus]
das ist sitzungsbeginn war 39 alle
wussten dass
amazon er schwebt in großer gefahr die
gesamte bevölkerung hat sich dem protest
angeschlossen nicht mehr nur die
eingeborenen sich doch alle sind
beteiligt
wir wollen eine demokratische debatte
wenn wir verlieren verlieren wir wenn
wir gewinnen gewinnen wir so
funktioniert demokratie es gehört auf
die agenda das thema ist abgeschlossen
die regierung und ihre partei sollten
das volk um verzeihung bitten sie haben
uns in eine sackgasse manövriert
wir sind bei einem anderen thema sie
haben ihren antrag durchgesetzt aber was
wird passieren wenn die bevölkerung am
amazonas davon erfährt
entschuldigen sie das thema ist
abgeschlossen
natürlich das thema ist hier
nicht jedoch am amazonas
vielen dank
[Musik]
[Applaus]
unser volk hatte gehofft gesetzt sie 90
würde heute abgeschafft
wenn dem so wäre könnten wir unseren
protest umgehend einstellen
ist beim organisation
[Musik]
sie sind tot dort hinten liegen zwei
tote
[Musik]
wir bleiben hier wenn sie uns töten
töten sie uns
[Applaus]
in gelbem hemd
wir haben viele schwerverletzte
wir stecken mitten in einem
schrecklichen konflikt
sie schießen überall mit tränengas um
sich
wir wissen nicht was los ist wir haben
von toten und verletzten erfahren aber
wir können unmöglich dort hinkommen
[Applaus]
verletzt ein polizist
könnte tot sein
wir werden das hier für unsere
gefallenen kollegen zu ende bringen und
für sie denn sie schauen nur auf uns wir
bringen es zu ende aber niemand wird ein
finger ohne dass ich jetzt sage was
ist denn los gehts kriegen wir es zu
ende denkt dann unser motto niemals
aufgeben
ich höre brennender in die kamera
schaut dem krankenwagen nach waffen
noch höher ausgehen können
sagte sagte ich habe gar nichts
er hat eine waffe
er hat eine gestohlene waffe er hat
damit geschossen
nehmen sie einen gürtel und fliehen
zwei stunden später verlagert sich der
konflikt von der teufels kurve in eine
nahe gelegene stadt
[Musik]
sie zielen auf menschen
die werden sich erschließen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
lang zurück geht aus dem weg
beim kampf an der teufels kurve werden
82 demonstrieren der eingeborenen und
zivilisten angeschossen
[Musik]
elf polizisten sterben eine verschwindet
spurlos
9 1 geborene männer sterben
[Musik]
ich möchte diesen akt verurteilen und
seine brüder
sie haben sie getötet einfach erschossen
dieses stück papier
die regierung hätte es zu reißen und ein
neues schreiben können
doch leben sind unwiederbringlich
verloren
niemand kehrt vom tode zurück
es ist eine schande für eine
demokratische regierung ferrara dazu zu
bringen einander zu töten
nun auf mich ist ein haftbefehl
ausgestellt worden
dennoch schuldet uns die regierung
rechenschaft
wurde für all die toten des heutigen
tages
was ist mit den toten polizisten
unser volk hat nur seine rechte
verteidigt
der präsident alan garcía
unsere brüder hatten sich friedlich
versammelt bis die polizei das feuer
eröffnete
sie war nicht bewaffnet
warum sind denn die polizisten tot
vielen dank
nein
werden sie sich stellen
[Musik]
die regierung handelte wie eine
demokratische regierung gemäß ihrer
verfassung handeln sollte
wir müssen zunächst ordnung und
disziplin in unserem land herstellen
polizisten wurden ermordet
das fünf wurden im hinterhalt mit
speeren getötet
hier starben beim versuch die straße
zurück zu erobern
elf tote polizisten
nicht die eingeborenen sind die opfer
sondern die polizei
solche ereignisse geschehen nicht durch
göttliche fügung
dies geschah planvoll durch aufrührer
pizarro ist zweifellos verantwortlich
vielleicht nicht in materieller weise
sicher jedoch intellektuell
reagierte drängte täuschte und
manipulierte die eingeborenen
indem er ihnen sagte irland wäre bereits
verkauft und das wasser privatisiert
sie müssten um ihr leben kämpfen die
justiz sollte ihn schnell verhaften dann
mit der verbrecher pisano die volle
wucht des gesetzes zu spüren bekommt
was sollen wir tun
[Musik]
hier raus und rede mit ihnen
irgendwelche neuigkeiten wegen im
haftbefehl
macht die tür auf
gegen diesen
dazu
gehe hier langsam vorsichtig
[Musik]
von 418 hier sind die nachrichten
danke wir haben einen anrufer guten tag
hallo ich rufe an
was geschieht doch
wir haben eine anlage 638 polizistin und
ihren kommandanten als geiseln genommen
wir haben sie in die berge geführt
als reaktion auf die erschließung
unserer bürger
[Musik]
anlage 6 war eine reaktion auf vage
im radio war von einem völkermord an der
teufels kurve die rede das war eine
unwahre übertreibung
die nachricht
der zaun war nicht allzu stark also
rissen sie ihn nieder überwältigten die
waffen und drangen ein
[Musik]
ich sagte ihnen in meiner sprache brüder
wir sollten einander nicht verletzen
doch sie ignorierten ihre anführer und
alles geriet außer kontrolle
[Musik]
niemand hat den kommandanten von der
tollen schlusskurve berichtet
kommandant montenegro wusste von nichts
er sagte ich rede mit ihnen dann richten
wir das alles
die eingeborenen gingen auf ihn los
schlugen mit stöcken und alle möglichen
und beleidigten uns wie hunde würden
jetzt sterben
sie stecken uns alle in ein lagerhaus
wir hörten wie ein helikopter über uns
kreiste
er landete nicht wir glaubten nicht mehr
dass verstärkung kommen würde
nach stunden sagten sie zum kommandanten
wir sollten mit kommen
stellt euch in einer reihe auf und kommt
mit
dem namen 18 männer mit
[Musik]
ja
was sind ihre forderungen
der innenminister soll der polizei den
rückzug
was geschieht wenn die behörden dies
nicht
dann muss unser erfolg wird sie dann
leider hinrichten
das nicht aufhalten
[Musik]
das polizei überhaupt des landes
übergibt nun die peruanische flagge an
die familien von kommandant miguel
antonia montenegro castillo
ich bin dankbar dass ich so einen
wunderbaren mann an meiner seite hatte
er war ein guter sohn
ein guter bruder ein guter vater
er war 22 jahre lang mein wunderbarer
ehemann
diesem moment schmerzt uns alle die wir
dich liebten so sehr
wie versprechen dir aber dass wir mit
einer stärke weiterleben werden
diese blume soll ein symbol des friedens
für alle sein
für unsere eingeborenen brüder denen wir
nicht mit hass begegnen
haltet ihr mein mann besser gekannt
hätte dir in sicher geschützt
denn mein mann war der wundervollste
mensch der mir je hätte begegnen können
ich danke dir mein liebster
[Musik]
die ja
ich möchte zunächst die vielen
ermordeten polizisten er in
wilder barbarischer brutalität zu
erfahren
unser land wurde ziel einer verschwörung
die uns zurückhalten
die hre ab so der ideologie entstammt
dem neunzehnten jahrhundert
sie versammelten ihre armee tief im
regenwald im rückständigsten teil
unserer nation
[Musik]
wir suchen noch immer den leichnamen
eines polizisten
[Musik]
es geht so noch am leben
ich glaube dass er noch lebt ein
besucher der regierung nicht
funktioniert müssen sie die eingeborenen
fragen die wissen wo er ist
lebendig oder tot
[Musik]
die menschen im regenwald wissen wie man
denkt fühlt und liebt
man muss satire es ist so weit gekommen
weil wir unser land lieben
wie sollen wir uns gehör verschaffen
eruieren die regierung sagt lass die
straßen in ruhe das geht nicht
alan garcía was soll das volk tun wenn
man ihnen alles verweigert wie bekommen
sie sonst aufmerksamkeit um einen dialog
zu beginnen die gala ist nur photon es
ist nicht unsere schuld wie mir die
nichtraucher um die polizisten geben
sowie um unsere eingeborenen brüder aber
die polizisten werden helden genannt
weil sie gegen einen feind kämpften
brücke belehrungen lassen also wir jusos
kinder muss
[Musik]
wir haben es in die sangoma sühl gewehrt
und eine sichere ausreise für ihn
beantragt
damit wir es in die st uhr sicher von
peru nach nicaragua bringen können
[Musik]
aktuell warten wir darauf dass die
peruanischen behörden den antrag
bearbeiten
[Musik]
er hat in aller form zeigen können dass
er politisch verfolgt hat und
daher wurde ihm in einklang mit
internationalem recht asyl in unserem
land gewährt
der drahtzieher der aufrührer und
feigling ist geflohen
doch das gesetz wird siegen und die
beteiligten der massaker an der polizei
werden der gerechtigkeit nicht entkommen
in peru wird alberto pizango wegen
rebellion volksverhetzung mord und
verschwörung gegen den staat angezeigt
bei uns im studio innenministerin
mercedes cabanillas
die gerade von einer trauerfeier zu den
tragischen ereignissen kann
zehn weitere polizisten wurden heute tot
aufgefallen wir empfinden tiefste trauer
es sind zerstörerische kriminelle kräfte
am werk die diese männer dazu brachten
unsere brüder die polizisten
abzuschlachten
ein barbarischer akt sie sind barbaren
doch auch 15 eingeborene sind tot nein
ich glaube nicht dass es so viele sind
egal wie viele es hätten gar keine sein
müssen
im ausland glaubt man die polizei hätte
die eingeborenen angegriffen dass diese
ausgegrenzt und misshandelt würden
es ist andersherum
es ist aber ein politisches problem
nicht
es geht nicht um sie es war kein problem
das die polizei lösen kann es geht um
ihre ideologie
es eskalierte am freitag am donnerstag
beschloss der kongress gesetzt 10 90
nicht abzuschaffen die eingeborenen
empfanden das als hohen
dann schickt die regierung die polizei
und wirft damit ein brennendes
streichholz in das pulverfass
[Musik]
lang lebe der kampf der anatomischen
volker
lange der kampf des peruanischen volkes
die vorentscheidung
nieder mit den transnationalen
nieder mit der regierung gab es hier
landesweiten proteste
manche abgeordnete sagen das recht müsse
sich durchsetzen und das freut muss es
unterstützen
ich frage sie glauben sie sie hätten die
wahrheit gepachtet
sie könnten sie im irrtum sein
sind diese gesetze möglicherweise doch
verfassungswidrig
wir sind den toten gegenüber in der
pflicht
wir können nicht länger unsere
polizisten als kanonenfutter schicken
das policia local mir liegt das problem
ist politisch wie die co
das kabinett hat blut an den händen und
sollte sich auflösen
bei allem respekt ich werde nicht auf
dumme kommentare antworten
[Musik]
es sind
sie sagen wir haben blut an den händen
wie könnten wir es zurücknehmen
halten sie den mund
ich bitte um ordnung ruhe
währt der abgeordnete sie zwinge mich
die sitzung zu unterbrechen
die regierung hat weder polizisten noch
ureinwohner ermordet
das rechtssystem wird die schuldigen
finden
die menschen sind gestorben
ihre regierung ist dafür verantwortlich
und wird die schande dieser tode für
alle zeit tragen müssen
die geschichte wird über sie urteilen
ich beantrage die sofortige aufhebung
dieser gesetze da die regierung ihre
moralische stellung als dialogpartner
verloren hat
[Musik]
es ist zeit die geschehnisse zu erfassen
und zu verarbeiten
die fehler die gemacht wurden aus
welchen gründen auch immer
es ist richtig dass die gesetze
ursprünglich ohne mitwirkung von
vertretern der ureinwohner entstanden
dies geschah in der annahme ihre
gemeinschafts länder wären dadurch nicht
betroffen
der premierminister hat beschlossen von
neuem zu beginnen und die gesetze
aufzuheben einen neuen dialog
anzustreben und neue gesetze zu
entwerfen um unseren amazonas zu
bewahren
spannungen hervorrufen
ich musste erfahren dass eine zu
schnelle modernisierung des landes zu
konflikten führt
fürchten jedoch nicht den wandel wenn er
unser land voran
ohne jedoch tod und leid zu erdulden
kommt es dazu müssen wir das berichtigen
uns versöhnen und von neuem beginnen
das kabinett
hat einstimmig beschlossen die gesetze
aufzuheben
dies ist unsere empfehlung
sie aufzuheben
ich trat zurück nachdem ich das problem
berichtigt ich bin nicht geflohen gegen
den widerstand vieler baten wir den
kongress um die aufhebung dieser gesetze
erst nach der lösung der probleme nahm
ich meine politische verantwortung wahr
irgendjemand musste sich verantwortlich
sein
[Applaus]
weltkongress die abstimmung wird nun
beendet
66 stimmen dafür
29 dagegen keine enthaltungen
13 tage nach der eskalation in baakuba
coup der kongress zwei der umstrittenen
gesetze auf darunter auch forstgesetz 10
[Applaus]
lamento mut ich trage tiefe trauer
diejenigen menschen die ihr leben
verloren
dein schmerz tief in meinem herzen
allein schon die tatsache dass es tote
gab
es hätte nicht sein müssen er
wolle nie wieder geschehen
[Musik]
haus und meine heimat sind der amazonas
mein herz und meine gedanken sind noch
in der
[Musik]
die regierung sagt man würde uns
einbeziehen aber unter der hand macht
sie weiter geschäfte und lassen die
unternehmen gewähren
sie verkaufen nach wie vor den amazonas
[Musik]
ich sehe
spüren
er kenne
die größe der bedrohung für unsere welt
wie schwer wir sie verseuchen
wir bringen ein andauern
[Musik]
die pflanzen freuen sich gerade sehr
sie stillen ihren durst
ich glaube solange ich liebe muss ich
etwas unternehmen
[Musik]
darum beschloss ich zurückzukehren
es warten viele gefahren
[Musik]
die regierung will stärke und autorität
zeigen und mich darum verhaften lassen
ich trete für meine rechte ein und bin
darum ein verbrecher
darum muss ich zurück auch wenn man mich
einsperrt ich muss zurück
nieder mit den unterdrücken nieder mit
den unterdrückern
irgendwann raus aus amazonien
isango
sie vertreten die gefallenen polizisten
von jaguar dort drüben sind die
unterstützer von pisa was halten sie
davon
sie seien bürger dritter klasse und
zivilisierte menschen wie können sie
jemanden unterstützen der zur gewalt
aufhetzen
er ist einfach ein gangster boss
wie können sie jemanden unterstützen
derzeit an polizisten anstachelt
es gibt einen haftbefehl für alberto
pizango wegen volksverhetzung entführung
und verschwörung gegen den staat die
polizei ist mit einem großaufgebot am
flughafen
[Musik]
wir haben einen haftbefehl für sie
folgen sie uns
kommen sie bitte mit
sie müssen mehr gehen
[Musik]
was sagen sie sind wir auch die sonne
bedauern sie was sie getan haben
sagen sie uns die wahrheit
haben sie antwortet die polizei zu töten
was sagen sie mir die toten polizisten
sind sie frei
[Musik]
am tag nach seiner ankunft er wirkt sein
anwalt eine kaution und alberto pizango
kommt frei ihm drohen zwei verfahren für
die geschehnisse in bagua und bei anlage
[Musik]
ja
die vorwürfe wiegen schwer
alberto pan wird als aufrührer
eingekerbt er habe die demonstranten
überzeugt tödliche gewalt anzuwenden
die vorwürfe erfordern die höchststrafe
lebenslange haft
so funktioniert ein repressives regime
die regierung nutzt das strafrecht um
ein hindernis zu eliminieren
ich verlange dass den mördern der
polizisten gerechtigkeit widerfährt
ebenso jenen die die eingeborenen
töteten im labor wurde rast
los ist sie sollen sich nicht hinter der
politik verstecken können oder drucker
soll die justiz ihren natürlichen laufen
nehmen wieso politisierung die
verantwortlichen müssen bestraft werden
denn sie stehen nicht über dem gesetz
[Musik]
unsere anführer forderten uns nie zum
morgen
sie sollten freigesprochen werden aber
es gibt viel druck von politischen
akteuren ein exemplar pisano und den
anderen zu statuieren und so zukünftige
proteste zu unterdrücken
du warst lange weg
die rechte deiner brüder verteidigt hast
ich freue mich dass
ich mache mir wegen deiner situation
große sorgen beete in deinem namen zu
gott
warten sie hier
live in 3 sekunden
am 5 juni 2009 starben über 30 menschen
bei der konfrontation in bagamoyo basar
wurde nie gefunden
sein vater sucht noch immer nach ihm und
ist heute unser gast hallo
vielen dank für die einladung
es gab zwei fotos von eingeborenen die
meinen sohn mit namen lebte also noch
was sagt ihnen das bild
das sie ihnen eine ur einwohner gemeinde
gebracht haben als sein vater glaube ich
dass mein sohn noch lebt denn ich habe
noch keinen beweis für seinen tod
gesehen
viele väter haben ihre söhne verloren
sie könnten sie aber begraben
sie haben einen ort um sie zu besuchen
und ihren schmerz heraus zu lassen
ich muss weiter
bis gott mir hilft meinen sohn zu finden
sonst halt mein leben keinen cent
jetzt
freut mich sie kennenzulernen
ich will ehrlich sein
das geschehen ist es geschehen aber als
vater leide ich immer noch an den folgen
ich suche meinen sohn sie sind auch ein
vater richtig ja
ich würde ihnen empfehlen es nicht
länger in form von öffentlicher
strafverfolgung weiter zu betreiben
wir müssen vertrauen bei unseren brüdern
aufbauen
wir müssen ihnen zusichern dass sie
nichts zu befürchten haben dass es keine
vergeltung geben wird
ich möchte nicht mit der polizei
arbeiten ich weiß dass das zu nichts
führt was geschehen ist war fürchterlich
die menschen hatten angst
alles was ich will sind informationen
senior albert ii ich glaube er ist noch
in einer ihrer gemeinden
ich werde oft gefragt warum ich es tue
ich weiß es nicht wenn wir seine leiche
finden haben wir in wenigstens gefunden
schon ein einziger knochen würde mir
inneren frieden geben
[Musik]
ja
die angeklagten sollen sich bitte hier
ausweisen
[Musik]
dieses verfahren betrifft die ereignisse
des 9 april 2009
viele gruppen von ureinwohnern
protestieren und forderten dass die
regierung mehrere gesetze aufheben die
ihnen zufolge ihre interessen betrafen
im zusammenhang damit wurden polizisten
ermordet es gab verletzte und
sachbeschädigungen
wir werden zeigen dass der angeklagte
die protestierenden zu diesem verbrechen
anstachelte
[Musik]
der erste anklagepunkt lautet mord
aufgrund der tötung von polizisten
angeklagt
diego teams und santiago man ihn als
drahtzieher dieses verbrechens
ich war teil des
untersuchungsausschusses hier sind
unsere ergebnisse
es gab zwei wege den hügel hinauf die
polizei kam von hier
sie kamen so nah heran dass sie mit den
eingeborenen zusammenstießen
einige unserer leute wurden verletzt
erst einer dann zwei als der dritte
verletzt wurde geriet es außer kontrolle
sie schrien sie töten uns
sie nahmen ihre waffen
sie ergriffen ihren sohn lockt
dann töteten sie die anderen polizisten
warum töteten sie ihn nicht
das frage ich mich auch
der die befehle gab der kommandant sie
wollten ihn als geisel nehmen
aber als sie zur straße kamen war die
menschenmenge dort zu groß und außer
kontrolle
viele machten mit sie hatten machten
sie nahmen ihn mit zum fluss und
zerstückelten dort seinen leichter
dann warfen sie die teile in den fluss
förderten sie die proteste am amazonas
ich bin der vorsitzende einer
organisation
die dem willen ihres volkes folgt
unter keinen umständen und zu keiner
zeit
unterstützen wir jemals die anwendung
von gewalt
wiesen sie die ureinwohner an straßen zu
blockieren
nein auf keinen fall
ich folgte nur meiner pflicht das
anliegen meines volkes an die regierung
heranzutragen
wiesen sie die eingeborenen an sich der
polizei zu widersetzen ihre position auf
der straße verteidigung
nicht wie sie zu keinem zeitpunkt an
wiesen sie die eingeborenen an tödliche
gewalt gegen polizisten auszugeben
ich möchte ihnen vielmehr die sichtweise
meines volkes näher bringen ich bin vom
folgt der campo pia wie unser prinzip
ist der schutz allen lebens
wir können nicht
unsere philosophie gestattet nicht
einmal das töten eine ameise denn auch
sie hat das recht zu leben
den dollar wieder diesem prinzip folgend
habe ich als präsident von eidos niemals
zur nutzung von gewalt aufgefordert oder
aufgerufen
[Musik]
das bescheidene fall jene die für irland
arbeiten
beklagen 23
toten das macht hungers der regierung
weil sie den reichtum des amazonas an
fremde länder verkaufen wollen
private unternehmen und die regierung
bereich hat sich und das ist der preis
was ist los mit dieser welt in der öl-
oder ein stück gold mehr wert ist als
ein menschenleben
[Musik]
das ist das staatsgebiet perus eines der
wenigen gebiete der welt die noch kaum
erforscht sind
dies ist gerade erst der anfang der
möglichen entdeckung die spitze des
eisbergs in vielen gebieten wurde noch
nicht gebohrt und für weite teile des
landes gibt es noch keine lizenzen
die lizenzen wurden aufgehoben durch die
projekte schreiten fort auch die
abschaffung der gesetze konnte die
entwicklung am amazonas nicht aufhalten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hallo alberta
[Musik]
die welt ist im wandel
die tiere jede einzelne natürliche
ressourcen auszubeuten
nach die menschheit blind
und sahen für alberto pizango wird etwas
sagen einen herzlichen applaus
albert es bei uns
wir die eingeborenen völker kämpfen um
unser überleben
wir werden kämpfen damit die menschheit
immer einen regenwald haben wird
unsere gemeinschaft unser volk
hier sind die beschützer der natürlichen
rohstoffe
dies ist unser zuhause
dies ist unser land
keine regierung libyen wird hier in
unserer heimat kommen
und unser land zerstören können
[Applaus]
[Musik]
und der zweite folgt nie besiegt werden
seit alan kassier 2011 aus dem amt
schied er ließ die peruanische regierung
neue gesetze zur förderung der
rohstoffindustrie
eingeborene und umweltschützer halten
diese gesetze weiterhin für eine gefahr
für die rechte der eingeborenen und den
umweltschutz
trotz der zusage der regierung die
abholzung bis 2021 einzustellen nahm die
rodung des peruanischen amazonas weiter
zu
[Musik]
2016 wurden alberto pizarro und 52
andere eingeborene im fall webber frei
gesprochen
noch bevor die verhandlung zur anlage 6
für ihn und 26 andere begonnen hatte
kein regierungsvertreter wurde angeklagt
alan garcía lehnte mehrere interview
anfragen für diesen film ab
[Musik]